niedergeschlagen aus beraubt liegen
gelassen und alles gefilmt von einer
handykamera
dieses video hier aus dem
bahnhofsviertel frankfurt stockt heute
morgen deutschland der hotspot der
heroin und crack szene ein junger mann
mit halbglatze wird von vier anderen am
straßenrand erst umzingelt sie streiten
dann der schock plötzlich holt einer der
männer mit basecap ausschlägt dem opfer
unbemerkt mit voller wucht ins gesicht
der getroffene verliert das bewusstsein
kippt nach hinten um beim aufprall aufs
pflaster ein harter dumpfer ton er
bleibt regungslos auf dem rücken liegen
die schläger beugen sich über den
bewusstlosen durchsuchen ihnen greifen
in seiner hosentasche rauben ihn aus und
kurz darauf flüchteten die täter lassen
das opfer ohnmächtig zurück und die
passanten die laufen einfach weiter die
polizei kennt den fall bereits hat aber
schwierigkeiten bei den ermittlungen
denn das opfer selbst meldet sich nicht
bei der polizei
und darüber wollen wir sprechen mit
unserer bild reporterin daniela paarte
sie ist am hauptbahnhof in frankfurt
daniela was genau ist passiert
genau dieses video diese 26 sekunden
video ist wohl vor einer woche
entstanden laut polizei dienstag oder
mittwoch und auch diesem video sieht man
eben eine gruppe von vier männern und
einer frau die irgendwie in streit
geraten
laut starken diskussion und in einem für
das opfer unbemerkten moment schlägt
dann einer dieser männer
lacht mit dem kopf auf den asphalt
aufschlägt
der mann wird bewusstlos
täter haben dann dieses opfer dann auf
dem boden diesen großen mann auf dem
boden liegend noch nach
wertgegenständen
haben ihnen sogar auf den bauch gerollt
um noch an die gesäßtasche zu kommen und
ja letztendlich konnten diese täter dann
unerkannt flüchten
das opfer bewusstlos zurück wir schon
gerade auch angesprochen die
ermittlungen in dem fall sind sehr sehr
schwierig denn weder täter noch opfer
sind bekannt dass ein täter flüchtig ist
das ist er erstmal nichts ungewöhnliches
aber dass ein opfer nicht identifiziert
ist das ist ja eher eine seltenheit und
das könnte eben daran liegen dass das
opfer selbst aus dieser drogenszene im
bahnhofsviertel stammen könnte und
selbst angst hat vor strafrechtlichen
konsequenzen und sich deshalb nicht bei
der polizei meldet die polizei wertet
jetzt aktuell überwachungskameras aus
ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen dass so
genannte super recognizr zum einsatz
kommen die hat nämlich die frankfurter
polizei
das sind beamte die sich gesichter sehr
sehr gut merken können und die
abgleichen können
die selbst eine gewisse
fotodatenbank im kopf haben und leute
oder täter schneller erkennen können als
andere menschen und es werden auch
weiterhin ganz ganz dringend zeugen
gesucht stand fest steht es gibt
unmittelbare tatzeugen
dann jeder du hast gesagt der dieser
diese tat ist im bahnhofsviertel von
frankfurt passiert der hotspot der
heroin und crack szene warum ist dieser
bereich zur no-go-area verkommen
ein ganz praktisches beispiel zu geben
wir haben uns hier ganz bewusst dagegen
entschieden uns mit der schaltung hier
direkt ins bahnhofsviertel zu begeben
auch auf polizeilichen rat hin weil man
einfach nicht garantieren kann dass die
situation ruhig bleibt dass es nicht zu
aggressionen kommt das bahnhofsviertel
in frankfurt war schon immer ein
problemviertel aber corona hat das ganze
noch mal verschärft
wir konnten in den letzten zwei jahren
sehr sehr oft mit gewerbetreibenden und
auch mit anwohnern sprechen und die
sagen die aggressionen haben zugenommen
das was vielleicht vorher hinter
verschlossenen türen stattgefunden hat
findet jetzt auf offener straße statt es
wird auf der offenen straße gedealt es
wird auf der werden auf der offenen
straße drogen konsumiert auch die
frankfurter müllentsorger beispielsweise
die gehen teilweise nur noch mit
polizeischutz hier ins bahnhofsviertel
um ihren job zu erledigen
die situation hat sich verschärft
unglaublich vielen dank für die
kreationen an unserem bild reporter